[Musique]
Ivan RL bonjour nous vous recevons
aujourd'hui pour une chaîne Youtube qui
s'appelle seriew nous vous recevons en
tant que porte-parole de la chaîne
sputnic France méia russe qu'est-ce qui
vous a amené à travailler pour sputnic
France alors moi j'a j'ai été
journaliste pendant plus d'une dizaine
d'années euh j'avais arrêté au profit du
du documentaire journaliste pour qui et
où euh j'ai bossé un peu pour tout le
monde j'ai bossé pas mal pour la croix
euh pour Marianne Europe 1 j'étais
plusieurs années à Europe 1 le nouvel
Ops peut-être le nouvel Ops un peu alors
le nouvels très peu puisque ma mère y
avait travaillé et je souhaitais pas
travailler là où avait travaillé ma mère
d'ailleurs dans l'ensemble tout ce que
j'ai fait c'était plutôt sous pseudo
avec un autre nom que celui de ma mère
pour pourquoi un pseudo ben c'est pas un
pseudo en fait c'est c'est je porte le
nom de ma mère je l' fait avec le le nom
de mon père pour pas pour pas trop jouer
les fils d'e voilà fils de qui fils de
Catherine
Erel qui était qui fait Libé et LOPS
essentiellement plutôt sur des
problématiques nationales moi j'étais
intéressé par les problématiques
internationales euh ça change rien au
fait que on a vite fait on fait vite le
le procès d'être à certains postes parce
qu'on est pistonné par un aîné voilà
pourquoi pourquoi votre patron il s'est
dégonflé de venir chez nous parce qu'il
a été très échaudé de son passage à
arrêt sur image où il avait en fait un
contradicteur
euh et qui s'est retrouvé avec et
schneederman et le chroniqueur qui
organisait le débat contre lui donc il
était seul contre entre TR
euh il s'est retrouvé il s'est retrouvé
un peu un peu désarmé et il a pas pu
placer ses arguments donc il s'est dit
les interventions comme ça c'est pas
pour moi si c'est pour me faire démonter
et démonter mon média ça sert à rien
donc là il a envoyé un professionnel de
la rhétorique et de la dialectique pour
nous alors je suis pas professionnel de
la rhétorique la dialectique je suis
donc j'étais G journaliste je connais
bien la je connais bien la presse vous
êtes français ouais j'ai de vraie
raisons de j'ai de vraie raison de
participer à spoutnque Vous avez un
casier judiciaire non pourquoi c'est des
raisons de participer à spoutnque bah
parce que moi j'étais correspondant au
Venezuela j'ai j'ai un regard critique
sur la la presse depuis
toujours j'étais correspondant au
Venezuela j'ai j'ai j'ai vu j'ai vu ce
qu'on pouvait
attendre d'un journaliste sur place
c'est souvent un passe- plat et dans
l'ensemble dans l'ensemble je trouve
qu'il y a dans la presse
une
unanimité qui qui est dangereuse
finalement pour la vérité c'est qui
c'est quoi la vérité à la vérité en
général se
situe en marge de ce qui est écrit dans
la presse donc la presse quand la presse
décide de parler de quelque chose de
faire une campagne sur un sur un
problème ou contre quelqu'un
il y a toujours des intérêts derrière
toujours toujours toujours et derrière
sputnck c'est quoi les intérêts bah
derrière Spoutnik c'est il a y a il y a
un double un double intérêt je dirais
c'est d'une part faire entendre le point
de
vue je dirais dans un premier temps je
dirais le point de vue de la Russie
parce que la Russie est présentée
partout comme le mal l'ennemi à battre
alors que bah alors que c'est un membre
permanent du Conseil de sécurité enfin
c'est c'est quelqu'un avec qui les
statuts de l'ONU prévoyait de composer
bon depuis depuis la chute de l'URSS on
compose plus du tout avec avec ce grand
pays c'est qui est une grande puissance
et et il est important que son point de
vue soit au minimum connu on dit pas qui
qui qui son point de vue na pas à
s'imposer aux autres réalité mais il
faut au moins entendre ce qu'ils ont à
dire combien ça gagne un porte-parole
par chez
sputnck pas énorme enfin pas énorme ça
gagne mieux ça gagne je pense que en
tout cas pour un journaliste débutant à
spoutnic je pense que ça gagne les
conditions sont meilleures un
journaliste débutant chez spoutnck il
est à combien et un porte-parole il est
à combien euh je dirais qu'un
journaliste débutant
est doit être
à à de Smic et un porte-parole pareil
voilà un peu plus vos sources de revenus
votre business modèle chez sputnque vous
recevez 100 % de votre argent de Moscou
est-ce que vous avez des revenus
publicitaires est-ce que vous touchez
des subventions est-ce que vous avez une
carte de presse alors certains ont des
cartes de presse pas tous on est aussi
on a un système aussi où où il y a il y
a deux statutes il y a des journalistes
et des producteurs les producteurs étant
euh censé aider les les journalistes à à
trouver des des interlocuteurs euh ce
qui est pas toujours
évident moi j'ai un peu l'impression que
tout le monde fait plus ou moins un
boulot de journaliste maintenant quand
on voit ce que la carte de presse enfin
à qui la carte de presse est accordée à
qui elle ne l'est pas je pense que de
toute façon là-dedans il y a il y a il y
a il y a quand même un problème qui est
peut-être plus lié d'ailleurs aux
réduction d'impôt enfin il y a moi je
connais des des des des des des des gens
qu' qu' on la carte de presse alors
qu'il font du casting pour des boîtes de
prod euh il y a d'autres gens qui font
un boulot formidable de journalistes euh
qui ont pas les 50 % de revenus
euh avec des fiches de paye écrite
journaliste émanant de de d'organ de
presse reconnu par la commission euh qui
mérite largement la carte de presse et
qu' l'ont pas euh le business model de
sputnque bah le business model de
spoutnic c'est un média publ qui est
payé à 100 % par le ministère de la
culture russe qui est
international je dirais que c'est le
même que RFI ou France 24 ou ou des des
des médias comme ça on parle pas de la
FP parce que lafp la FP a dans ses
statuts interdiction d'être financé par
par par le gouvernement bon alors pour
compenser ça il y a 40 % je crois ou
quelque chose comme ça des revenus de PR
alors c'est 40 % je rajoute quand même
je crois mais qui sont des
abonnements de d'entité publique plus ou
moins bidon c'estàd que il y a il y a
tout un tas de gens qui sont abonnés à
la FP qui n'en ont aucun usage et c'est
une subvention déguisée est-ce que vous
connaissez la charte de munique la
charte de munique non c'est
compliqué charte de munique les droits
et devoirs du
journalisme ça a été décidé à munique en
quelle
année c'était aux alentours de 70 je
crois non très bien donc vous votre fond
de roulement chez spoutnck c'est combien
alors euh il semblerait qu'on soit en en
légèrement en dessous de 100 millions de
dollars par an ouais pour sputniic
France non non sputnic monde sputnic
monde sputniic France il touche combien
aucune idée du tout du tout vous savez
combien de salariés
euh
10 plus d'une
dizaine plus d'une dizaines ouais tous
français ou tous russes
euh tous français à l'exception
de de de deux de deux don don le redac
chef donc il y a deux Russes et tous
français ouais et le deè russe c'est qui
la deuxème russe bah elle est
elle est euh elle était journaliste elle
est journaliste et là elle repart à
Moscou donc en fait comment elle
s'appelle euh Xenia lukianova d'accord
elle a quelle place dans ce bouttique
elle était journaliste au même titre que
les autres maintenant elle va elle va
plus se elle va plus se concentrer sur
le le site internet qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez répondre au journalistes français
qui vous jette l' prob en
pardon j'ai un truc qui siffle pardon
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez répondre aux
journalistes qui répondent ou qui vous
jettent le prob en vous disant que vous
êtes la voix du
FSB la voix de la propagande russe et
que vous êtes vecteur de fake news alors
on va prendre un par un alors d'abord
être la voix de quel est-ce qu'on est la
voix de celui qui nous
finance est-ce que on est la voix de
d'assaut est-ce qu'on est la voix de
buig est-ce qu'on est la voix de Free
euh est-ce qu'on voilà les les les les
médias français sont à 90 % financés
par des grands
industriels qui viennent des télécoms de
l'armement du
bâtiment de la banque qu'on àoir ces
gens-là avec la presse si ce n'est le
désir de la contrôler alors ça c'est une
première chose donc je leur dirais de
regarder du côté de leur financement à
eux
et du travail qu'ils font eux-mêmes sur
les malversation éventuelle de ces
grandes sociétés
euh le
FSB en arrivant à Spoutnick je me disais
c'est super on va avoir des supers
informations première main rendez-vous
direct avec les les services donc le FSB
non communique très très peu très très
mal et en tout cas bien moins que les
renseign enseignement français qui
balance à droite à gauche des infos qui
les arrangent le FSB fait pas ça vous
avez des sources pour les services
français dans quel canard il
balanceraiit des infos euh bah dans dans
dans tous les canards
quand certains enfin le monde le Canard
enchaîné et tous disent selon les
sources de renseignement selon les
sources proche du renseignement selon
voilà ça c'est pas donc le FSB fait pas
trop fuiter de choses chez vous c'est ça
rien du tout rien du tout et c'est enfin
c'est c'est leur façon de communiquer
hein c'est moi je je je j'en suis
presque est est-ce que vous sentez
l'administration russe présente dans vos
locaux est-ce qu'il y a non la main
est-ce que l'œil de Moscou veille sur
vous non euh par vous êtes totalement
indépendant si vous voulez traiter un
sujet sur Poutine Vladimir Poutine ou
sur la corruption qui peut y avoir en
Russie ou sur l'état des prisons ou sur
des choses comme ça ouais moi je pense
qu'il se passe alors l'état des prisons
je rebondis là-dessus parce que l'état
des prisons en France est déplorable
c'est un des pires au monde on il faut
jamais faut jamais se comparer au
derniers de la classe je suis d'accord
faut jamais se comparer au dernier de la
classe et en l'occurrence la France est
un des derniers de la classe donc on
peut pour voir comment ça se passe en
Russie mais en France on est vraiment
très très mauvais là-dessus il y a pas
encore de raquette en France quand même
de raquettes de raquettes sur les
détenus ah bon comment ah bon en France
il y a des raquettes sur les détenus
évidemment enfin il il y a tout ce qui y
a tout ce qu'il faut pas qu'il se passe
dans une prison ça se passe en France
hein d'accord ça enfin faut voir avec
faut voir avec les gens de l'OIP hein
qui sont plus spécialistes mais l'OIP
qui veut dire l'Observatoire
international des prisons euh qui a la
gentillesse de nous parler de temps en
temps et ça on parlera d'ailleurs de de
nos sources he des gens qui acceptent et
qui acceptent pas he bah on verra si on
en parle les questions ce ce profil ça
marche donc est-ce que l'œil de Moscou
veille sur vous est-ce que vous avez
tout je pense qu' je
penseous la même tendance la même
tendance qu'il y a chez les journalistes
français d'autres il y a une autocensure
chez sputnick il y a une autocensure
ouais je pense qu'il y a y a une
autocensure euh qui est aussi lié à à la
jeunesse du média he ça fait 2 ans qu'on
existe euh il y a des gens qui sont
motivés euh qui arrivve avec des envies
de bien faire de faire bouger les choses
de donner un point de vue alternatif euh
du coup il se il se concentrre sur il se
concentrent sur sur les gens qu'on qu'on
le plus souvent la parole et je veux
dire il y a pas besoin de spoutnic pour
pour donner des infos sur vraie ou
fausse sur ce qui peut se passer en
Russie avec
l'opposition avec Poutine avec la
liberté de la presse euh voilà la
liberté de la presse
elle existe partout elle est
manipulé partout c'est ça elle est
partout et nulle part c'est ça c'est ça
et le le pire ennemi aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui le le le pire ennemi de du
journaliste c'est l'autocensure qui est
très forte très très forte l'autocensure
et le conformisme euh je veux dire alors
la devise de spoutnic c'est c'est quoi
c'est euh on par telling the untold donc
on dévoile ce que les autres ce dont les
autres ne parlent pas vous avez dé
dévoiler quoi par rapport aux autres
c'est qui les autres déjà bah
déjà les autres c'est toute la presse
contre vous ou c'est un peu ouais un peu
oui des des enfin quand on voit sur des
problématiques comme qui nous
intéressent on est quand même très
orienté sur la presse internationale
enfin sur du la
géopolitique les pages
internationales des différents journaux
euh quand on voit l'unanimité avec
laquelle sont traités des sujets
comme l'Ukraine ou la Syrie on se dit
qu'il y a un loup et on se dit qu'il a
un loup parce que vous vous êtes
journaliste ou c'est l'œil de Moscou qui
vous dit qu'il y a un loup alors en ce
qui
concerne bah d'abord parce que je suis
journaliste et que je sais que je sais
que quand quand il y a quand tout le
monde est d'accord c'est qu'il y a un
problème d'autre part concernant
l'Ukraine c'est parce que j'y suis allé
de nombreuses fois où ça va bah Kiev
carc pof comment on dit bonjour en
ukrainien ah je sais pas je sais pas j'y
suis allé avec un fixeur avec plusieurs
fixeurs du côté ukrainien ou du côté
russe les deux les deux c'était
compliqué de travailler du côté
ukrainien pas du tout pas du tout pas du
tout ils éta même en tant que Médi russe
ah moi j'étais pas en tant que Médi
russe j'étais pas en tant que médiia
russe je m'occupé d'un d'un film
euh qui s'appelait qui s'appelait euh
Poutine pour toujours c'est un
film violemment critique de de Poutine
euh qui a été taxé de propagande
occidentale euh antipoutine aveugle et
cetera euh et cela dit euh j'étais
j'étais vraiment étonné du pouvoir des
des milice de pravisector
euh et de swvoboda en Ukraine euh euh pr
sector donc moi je j'accompagnais ils
avaient pas honte du tout de ce qu'il
faisait moi il m'ont très gentiment
amené en en ratonnade c'est c'est un des
moments les plus gênants de ma carrière
de de journaliste euh je leur demandais
mais qu'est-ce que vous faites le soir
ils disent ah bah on cherche on cherche
des gens avec des drapeaux communistes
ou des drapeaux
russes on fait des on fait des rondes
alors je dis onemz-moi en ronde les mecs
il me font monter dans leur voiture avec
la caméra et bon bah finalement ils ont
pas trouvé de communistes donc ils sont
allés se rabattre sur les squat des
clandestins euh d'Asie centrale ils
arrivent et ils cassent les bouteilles
et il les cont contrôle les
identités
et moi en tant journaliste c'est la
première fois que que je me fais Gerber
un peu parce que j'ai rien fait mais en
même temps voilà j'avais les je les
avais la main dans le sac mais ils s'en
foutent ils s'en foutent ils sont ils
sont contents de ce qu'ils font ils sont
contents de ce qu'ils font et tout le
monde sait ce qu'ils font tout le monde
sait ce qu'ils font quand quand Paul
morira a sorti son film hyper soft
sur le réel pouvoir de de l'extrême
droite en en Ukraine et et de et de et
de de ces gens qui ont qui ont Swoboda
qui a qui a eu des ministères qui a est
pour vous a engagé
euh je crois
ouais je crois enfin parce que j'avais
un tropisme sur sur la Russie en ce
moment j'en ai eu d'autres et parce que
et parce que j'étais journaliste et
parce que j'avais un discours parce que
j'avais un discours sur le discours de
la presse je dire comme Mora a sorti son
son son documentaire sur l'Ukraine il y
a toute la presse qui lui est tombée
dessus je sais plus combien 30 ou 50
correspondants correspondant qui avait
bossé sur l'Ukraine qui ont qui lui ont
fait une lettre ouverte insultante pour
dire qu'il avait rien compris à
l'Ukraine et que il avait manipulé
l'information alors qu'il n'avait fait
que relater ce qu'il avait vu et il
avait pas vu grand-chose par rapport à
ce qui peut se passer mais d'autres ont
vu exactement
l'inverse d'autres ont vu que pravis
sector n'exerce pas le rôle de police en
Ukraine ça c'est facile de le voir voilà
bah il y a des gens qui l'ont vu et qui
l'ont pas dit
lesquels tous les autres comment il
s'appellent
tu veux des noms
ouais euh comment il s'appelle euh bah
Aï a a j'ai oublié Piotre quelque chose
j'ai oublié en tout cas le le mec le mec
du monde qui maintenant est à Jérusalem
euh voilà qui a eu sa promotion après
avoir fait son boulot sur l'Ukraine il a
fait ça est-ce que vous avez déjà traité
des sujets contre Poutine chez
sputnck il y en a beaucoup à ce pointl
directement directement je crois pas je
crois que ça va je crois que ça va
devenir possible ça va devenir possible
ça pour l'instant pour l'instant il y en
a peut-être pas ouais bah si bien sûr
qu'il y en a il y en a bien sûr qu'il y
en a bien sûr qu'il y en a mais tant
que je dire tant que
la les médias focalisent sur une
opposition qui t tous les gens qui
parlent de
Russie sont des gens issus en France
sont des gens issus ou s tien d'une
opposition qui représente 4 à 5 % de la
de la l'électorat russe euh trois
qualités et trois défauts de la
Russie trois qualités et trois défauts
de la Russie alors
euh trois je commencer par les défauts
euh ils sont
euh en entier dans le sens où ils
chercheront ils chercheront pas euh la
la la nuance forcément
euh un autre
défaut un autre défaut il croit pas euh
à la la la CRO à la démocratie
occidentale comme modèle universel
applicable partout
euh
euh et un autre défaut je dirais ça
c'est un peu personnel je pense qu'ils
sont
euh sont un peu religieux
euh en
qualité en qualité ils se battent pour
une une cause
juste est le le le pluralisme à la fois
de l'information de l'exercice du
pouvoir et
euh et euh et du partage des des des des
richesses et et et des zones
d'influence en autre qualité
euh ils ont rien dit quand ils sont fait
piquer la victoire de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale parce qu'ils l'ont dit le
problème c'est qu'ils ont communiqué
beaucoup à l'intérieur mais à
l'extérieur on a fini par être convaincu
que c'était les Américains qui avaient
gagn la Seconde Guerre mondiale depuis
combien de temps vous travaillez chez
eux euh 6 mois vous pensez que ça va
durer
je sais pas vous avez un CDD ou un CDI
euh un CDD faot de salaire il est
verersé en France ou en Russie en
France en France
euh mais oui non mais cette histoire de
Seconde Guerre mondiale c'est c'est
marrant parce que euh ils vous ont
bombardé porte-parole il y a combien de
temps euh quand je suis arrivé il y a
combien de temps 6 mois il y a 6 mois
ouais
ou
ouais la la Seconde Guerre mondiale ça
t'intéresse pas on connaît bien le sujet
d'accord bon ben tant pis bon maintenant
l'avenir de sputnque alors l'avenir de
sputnic moi ça ça m'intéresse vachement
parce que
euh bon on nous aime pas on a fait notre
petit effet
euh ça y est là on commence à
s'intéresser à nous on commence à nous
scruter
euh je pense que il faut qu'on soit plus
nombreux donc il faut qu'on recrute euh
qu'on étend notre réseau radio à des
zones
francophones qu'on avait pas prévu dire
on a une grosse audience en Afrique
ouais on a une grosse audience en
Afrique du Nord et en Afrique
sub-saharienne je pense que c'est des
choses qu'on peut qu'on peut développer
parce que
euh hors de France dans la zone
francophone les les gens on pas du tout
du tout le même point de vue on va au
Maroc le problème de la Syrie il est
traité mais complètement différemment
ils en ont voilà ils veulent pas des
djihadistes ils considèrent l'opposition
comme djihadiste voilà c'est clair et
net pour eux donc euh on
a donc on va je voudrais qu'on se
développe par là-bas je voudrais aussi
qu'on a un peu plus de temps pour se
libérer du flux de l'info au profit de
au profit au profit d'enquête vous avez
du budget pour faire des enquêtes bah
éventuellement on pourra avoir du budget
combien combien touche sputning France
déjà par an je sais pas
d'accord je sais pas
mais le budget le budget qu' a sur
toutes les antennes de
Spoutnick me
semble accessible accessible ou enfin en
tout cas je pense qu'on on aurait les
moyens on aurait les moyens voloco se
trouve où dans le
17e quand j'ai j'ai j'ai cru lire un
papier contre vous comme quoi c'était
très difficile de vous joindre ind on a
on a mis 7 minutes à vous joindre c'est
non mais on voulait quand même le
rédacteur en chef mais bon ouais B enfin
vous l'avez joint et vous avez mis 7
minutes à nous joindre mais en même
temps on va pas leur jeter la pierre je
veux dire c'est des c'est 19 ans ils ont
19 ans les gens confessent c'est le
papier ouais c'est ça pense ce
papier voilà ils ont ils ont ils ont
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de Rusia
toutday est-ce que c'est le grand frère
de sputnck est-ce que c'est le dans dans
dans le même bois c'est une télé il
remplissent nous on est une agence
internationale multimédia c'est qu'on
est très web euh un peu vidéo et et
radio donc la Radio la radio nous prend
beaucoup de temps votre audience c'est
quoi euh notre audience c'est 25 35
euh chiffres euh la proportion h on doit
être à la à
60 on doit être à 70 % en dessous de 35
ans euh 25 35 35 45 ouais c'est ça ouais
euh vous homme femm homm femm beaucoup
beaucoup de femmes aussi vous utilisez
des utilitaires pour sonder un peu votre
communauté bah pas assez moi j'ai enfin
on est on on fait nos analyses Google
Analytics là j'ai j'ai commandé un
rapport mais bon il faut faut l'attendre
euh je suis assez je suis assez fasciné
par tout ça ça parce que c'est c'est
assez nouveau c'est c'est intéressant
c'est plutôt des gens éduqués c'est
aussi des gens qui lisent le reste de la
presse et qui viennent et qui viennent
sur spoutnic Chercher lire des infos
qu'ils ont pas ou ou une autre vision
des des mêmes questions
euh ce que je trouve assez intéressant
comme démarche et je regrette que en
fait les les journalistes fassent pas la
même quoi quand vous vous retrouvez à
traiter des sujets un peu complexes
compliqués et
arid votre rédaction vous laisse
la plus grande latitude ou pas ouais
ouais en même temps on prend pas
vraiment de risque on on fait comme tout
le monde on cherche des on cherche des
spécialistes on cherche des spécialistes
des des inter comment ça se passe les
les les salles de rédaction chez
sputnick
on on se réunit le matin on dit tel et
tel sujet donc on a un nombre limité de
de journalistes donc on dit on décide de
trois sujets général euh
deux ou trois commentaires ce qu'on
appelle commentaires qui sont des des
des interviews et C ou si brèves
euh en fait ce qui sert ce qui ce qui
sert de ce qui axe un peu notre notre
travail c'est c'est l'émission radio
donc vous avez qui en émission radio
vous avez qui combien d'émissions radio
combien de bah on a tous les jours tous
les jours de 17 à 19h sur la fréquence
de radio àigre pour l'instant euh
bientôt donc en Île-de-France seulement
bientôt dans d'autres régions de
France et peut-être à l'étranger plus
tard donc c'est c'est une émission de 2h
2h de contenu exclusif
euh qui
est compose donc qui est composé pour
une demi-heure d'un show de soit Rachel
Maren soit Jacques Sapir plus 1h3
c'est-à-dire trois journaux en fait
euh de qui sont qui sont présentés par
qui qui sont le travail de la rédaction
et qui sont présentés par Édouard Chanot
et Marie Clarville comment vous êtes
jugé par vos confrères français d'autres
d'autres journaux ou d'autres télés bah
je pense que pour
l'instant pour l'instant on est on est
jugé on est jugé comme comme
agande je pense un juste titre ou pas
non il devrait nous juger en tant que
point de vue
alternatif voilà y a d'autres points de
vue qui existent il y a pas une
vérité je pense que ça vaut le coup de
se renseigner sur sur les points de vue
des autres plutôt que de croire que
parce qu'on travaille au monde on
incarne la vérité parce que c'est faux
c'est faux le monde m comme tout le
monde pourquoi pourquoi le monde
ment pourquoi le monde ment parce que
pourquoi vous mtez moins que le monde
parce que parce que le monde c'est la
référence absolue de la presse française
référence absolue je je quand quand
quand lib sort un scoop ça n'est pas un
scoop tant que c'est pas repris par le
monde et quand le monde le sort il se
gêne pas pour dire c'est un scoop c'est
nous qui l'avons sorti et et à vous
maintenant de reprendre de reprendre nos
infos ce que les gens font les
journalistes les journalistes la
première source des journalistes c'est
les autres journalistes donc il bossent
entre eux sur sur la les mêmes sujets
les mêmes infos les mêmes sources
quelles sont vos sources à vous chez
sputnck on a ça d'abord et ensuite on a
on a un chouix de réseau on a un chouix
de réseau international donc il y a
toutes les toutes les autres éditions de
sputnic qui nous envoie des trucs des
infos des interviews des commentaires
euh qui sont traduits alors là il y a un
service de il y a un truc de traduction
qui fait que on a une interview en
farcie qui qui va être traduite en russe
envoyée à toutes les rédactions et
retraduite en français ou en
espagnol avec parfois des qui est-ce qui
gère ça cette agence de traduction ça ça
se passe à au siège à Moscou vous avez
déjà visité les locau du siège non pas
encore je je pense que je vais y aller
je pense que je vais y aller c'est c'est
c'est enfin c'est c'est c'est une grosse
machine qu'est-ce que sputnick a déjà
sorti comme
scoop scoop là on a on a sorti un truc
là tout récemment sur
ranir qui qui touche des subventions
maquillées via une
association pour la promotion de
Montpellier qui qui facture 700000 € par
an un site internet bidon
euh qui qui en VO 80 % de de ses fonds
dans un dans un paradis fiscal donc il
nous ont écrit en disant c'est pas vrai
on touche pas de subvention illégale on
a évidemment publié leur leurs
commentaires et on là on va en rajouter
une couche sur les condamnations qu'ils
ont reçu partout en Europe pour des
subventions illégales ça j'aimerais bien
qu'on s'oriente vers des chos comme ça
qui est-ce qui enquéter sur cette
affaire euh ga Nicole combien de temps
euh de mois bah les enquêtes ça
fonctionne les enquêtes ça fonctionne
souvent pareil he il y a il y a une info
au départ qui vient d'une
source plus ou moins bien intentionnée
et qui ensuite il faut vérifier recouper
récupérer les documents qui a il a il y
a plusieurs styles d'enquête he il y a
des enquêtes comme ça qui qui viennent
d'une source et ensuite il y a plus qu'à
vérifier il y a les enquêtes laborieuses
où on on cherche on cherche on cherche
et on on finit par trouver et toute
façon toute façon quand quand on compile
un certain nombre d'informations on
arrive souvent à résumés intéressant
avec des des infos qu'on savait pas
les je dire c'est comme c'est comme
l'espionnage industriel l'espionnage
industriel c'est 80 % d'informations qui
sont dans le domaine public 90 90 % par
que voilà 90 % d'information ce n'est
pas mes mots ce sont les mot de Philippe
caduc qui est le directeur de laadite
voilà voilà c'est ça il suffit de
compiler des choses qui sont dans le
domaine public
ensuite de trouver la personne qui te
donnera les 10 % supplémentaires et et
tu arrive avec un truc plus ou moins
saignant plus ou moins g quand votre
rédacteur en chef se fait pas étrié mais
il se
retrouve pris entre en tenaille avec
Daniel Schneiderman et deux autres
acolytes
euh ça la refroidi beaucoup pas beaucoup
ouais ça la refroidi pas mal parce
que parce qu'en face il y avait
nicolasin sur qui il avait quelques
quelques vies quoi et nicolasin qui
était un
personnage très respecté autant que
très très très bizarre ou voilà très
décrié mais pas trop en public euh voilà
il intervient désormais comme un des
grands spécialistes de la Russie après
avoir été spécialiste des djihadistes
euh il parle ni le Russe ni l'arabe
c'est-à-dire que il n'a d'information il
n'a jamais d'information en version
originale vous parlez russe non ni
l'arabe
kououamam comment camam non je parle pas
tout va bien non voilà
et donc on le verra plus votre AAC
chef parce que nous on l'a rencontré
ouais on est très déçu on est très déçu
B ouais mais il était très content de
vous il était très content de vous voir
il a il a il a il a il a vraiment hésité
et puis euh en plus
bah donc il était vachement content de
de des discussions que vous avez pu
avoir en même temps tu as pas caché
que que vous étiez méchant et vous allez
être dur donc dit déjà les autres ils
ont dit t'inquiète pas on va être
équilibré il déboité autant vous
annoncez la couleur vous allez
dur B on représente notre communauté
c'est très bien notre communauté a des
questions notre communauté nous dit
est-ce que rouchatou et sputnck sont
l'œil de Moscou en France pour n sortir
de la propagande pour vous sortir de la
propagande ou pour vous y mettre c'est
pareil nous sortir nous servir de la
propagande russe non pour vous en sortir
pour vous en sortir parce que vous êtes
dans la propagande vous êtes dans la
propagande anglo-saxon et Rusia today
que je ne connais pas par ailleursnais
pas c'est une technique de
contrepropagande russe spoutnic et
France 24 pas pardon alors France 24
France 24 France 24 c'est de la
propagande française surtout à
destination de l'Afrique puisque il y a
plus là il y a du pouvoir donc c'est une
guerre de propagande journalistique à
travers ces médias là ouais je pense
c'est la véritable question en fait oui
voilà c'est ça c'est ça la vraie la
vraie question c'est est-ce que est-ce
que plusieurs points de vues sont
autorisés dans le monde pas seulement
alors donc la la France a perdu a perdu
sa guerre de la de
l'information France 24 a une
audience c'est quoi le petit surnom de
la
FP la il faut le dire non je sais pas si
si si si c'est quoi le petit surnom de
la FP Agence France propagande Agence
France propagande bah voilà mais cela
dit c'est agence propagande tout court
parce que la
FP n de française que le siège à
bourse le point de vue français à
l'international ne se distingue plus de
rur sa
pai comment on fait pour voir le patron
de ton patron fa voir le patron de mon
patron
euh faut qu'on aille faut qu'on aille
taper où à la porte du kemelin
il faut qu'on aille taper à la porte
d'une agence de presse russe
Landin ça c'est vraiment la question qui
remonte à chaque fois ouais qui est le
patron de mon patron qui est derrière
sputnck c'est que le ministre derrière
sputnck il y a une volonté non mais il y
a une volonté cl ouais il y a une
volonté étatique de de de de faire
parler le point de V rus sur les médias
voilà c'est c'est c'est c'est du c'est
du soft
power c'est assumé ouais oui oui c'est
est-ce que c'est plus assumé assumé
d'autant d'autant d'autant que la la la
presse est est sans limite quand il
s'agit de la Russie sans limite aucune
c'est quoi sans limite sans limite
c'est-à-dire que ça va
de de la
simple de la simple calomnie au rus
bashing et au putin bashing quoi alors
donc dès
que dès que dès qu'on ajoute russe à la
fin d'un mot ça fait ça fait euh FSB
dictature
sanglant monstrueux tout ce qu'on veut
euh voilà c'est un peu comme dans South
Park avec le Canada ouais oui c'est ça
c'est blem Canada blem rusa c'est ça bah
ouais ruchan didit il y a le hashtag
hashtag rushan didit voilà rusan didit
j'ai j'ai j'ai ça a pas l'air de trop
adhérer sur internet ça rushan didit
ouais ça fait marrer tout le monde ouais
ça fait marrer tout le monde ouais c'est
c'est je pense que c'est parti d'un d'un
vrai truc mais que mais que ça a viré à
la blague ça a viré à la blague mais
mais c'est une blague qui est
représentative de de de de de ce qu'on
dit dans dans la presse hein c'est c'est
c'est les Russes voilà il y a un
bombardement quelque part c'est les
Russes alors que alors-ces sont tout
blanc les Russes bah non je pense pas
aucun aucune grande puissance aucune
grande puissance n n'est toute blanche
mais comment on fait pour savoir s'ils
sont tout blanc ou ils sont tout noirs à
quel sein peut-on est-ce que l'opinion
publique peut jou est-ce que quelqu'un
peut croire que n'orte quelle grande
puissance puisse être toute blanche ou
toute noire moi moi moi je crois pas moi
moi je je lis la presse depuis
suffisamment longtemps pour savoir que
chacun défend ses intérêts où qu'il soit
euh évidemment que évidemment que la
l'intervention en Syrie est liée à à des
intérêts par pas seulement au fait de
pas de pas laisser sombrer ce pays euh
dans le chaos comme comme tous ces pays
où les États-Unis ont cherché à imposer
la
amené la la démocratie je parle de
l'Afghanistan l'Irak la Libye qui qui
sont qui ont fait un bon en arrière
enfin l'Afghanistan ça jamais
été sommet de la la modernité mais la
Libye la Libye et l'Irak avait des
régimes dictatoriaux
euh mais d'une part les populations
était bien plus en sécurité qu'elles ne
le sont aujourd'hui l'État fonctionnait
euh voilà aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est
deux pays je pas je connais bien l'Irak
c'est c'estes deux pays qui qui qui qui
vivent mal quoi qui vivent mal donc si
c'était pour faire péter la Syrie de la
même manière je crois pas que c'était
l'intérêt des Syriens la presse russe
locale vous la lisez ben non je lis pas
le Russe euh il y
a il y a plusieurs types de de presse
russe de de d'près ce que ce que je sais
là je sors de mes connaissances brutes
he là je je c'est des discussions que
j'ai avec avec Dimitri ou avec d'autres
euh il y a euh il y a de la presse
d'état ou euh ou de la presse
euh privée favorable pr gouvernemental
comme on pourrait dire et euh et de la
presse privée tout à fait libre et de la
presse privée d'opposition euh voilà et
il compris des y compris des chaînes
télé il y a une chaîne télé euh un des
pendante qui qui est qualifié en Russie
d'opposition qui a été récemment
interdite en Ukraine parce queelle était
considéré comme
prorusse
donc donc estce que la presse va bien en
Russie je sais pas j'en sais rien je
sais pas si la presse va bien je sais
qu'elle existe qui a un vrai lectorat
euh voilà est-ce que la presse va bien
en France on pourrait poser la même
question dans une dans une société où on
est complètement surinformé
euh voilà la presse se vend de moins en
moins quoi vos chiffres de progression
c'est quoi en un an on a doublé on est
l'audience ouais on a doublé l'audience
ouais on a doublé l'audience on
est autour de pas loin de 200000 vues
par jour
euh et on et on augmente on a enfin on a
on a vraiment des on a vraiment une
grosse audience à gagner autant des
autant des gens qui
seront qui seront convaincus que
d'autres gens qui qui nous qui se
servent de nous comme comme presse de de
complément est-ce que les services de
renseignement français vous ont à l'œil
euh non enfin qu'est-ce que je sais pas
je sais pas j'imagine parce que quand on
regarde quand on regarde ce fameux
scandale sur le les hackurs Russes et le
le piratage des élections
américaines quand on lit le rapport qui
est finalement
publié niveau hcking il y a rien grosso
modo le piratage c'est RA today et
spoutnck qui qui ont mené une campagne
d'information c'est de l'information
euh information ouais
bah je sais pas moi je trouve que c'est
plus un combat un combat de journaliste
qu'un combat d'état à état est-ce que
c'est du Social Engineering d'état à
état du Social Engineering tu peux me
rappeler la définition du social
engering l'ingénierie sociale
c'est-à-dire formater le point de vue de
la pleb à travers des médias ou des
influenceurs
ou des techniques comme l'astrurfing sur
internet je suis beaucoup moins au
point que toi sur ces sur ce vocabulaire
maintenant formater le point de vue des
masses
euh euh non n nous en tout cas on essaie
plutôt de donner une grille de lecture
on sait que on sait que on sait qu'on
est pour l'instant une presse de
complément euh et qu'il est important
que les lecteurs de lib de l'OP du
Figaro du monde
euh sacheent que d'autres choses
d'autres points de vue existent sur les
mêmes problématiques et que d'autres
informations qui mérite d'être
connu arrive en même temps al sans qu'on
en parle nécessairement nécessairement
dans le pluralité de l'information la
pluralité de l'information ouais quand
on regarde les commentaires de vos
articles sur les les réseaux sociaux h
est-ce que vous faites de la modération
euh un problème de la modération c'est
que c'est un vrai boulot et qu'on est un
peu en sous- effffectif donc vous en
faites ou vous en faites pas il y il y
en a un peu à chaque fois moi je dis
c'est pas possible on peut pas laisser
ça qu'est-ce que vous pouvez pas laisser
euh les des
insultes des
insultes est-ce que vous pensez que
votre public est principalement
constitué de gens à tendance d'extrême
droite non je pense qu'il y en a je
pense qu'il y en a mais c'est rigolo
parce qu'on on les voit souvent par
exemple sur les commentaires s'affronter
entre banlieu rebeux
et extrême droite euh on voit et et pas
toujours en étant pas toujours l'un
contre l'autre quoi des fois les deux
contre un autre et on voit un mec qui
est clairement qui est
clairement soit algérien soit marocain
soit soit de banlieu avec avec un autre
qui est clairement ou qui porte un
pseudo typique de Saint- François
d'Assise voilà Saint-François Dantis ou
typique typique fchosphère qui va euh
c'est quoi la fachosphère alors la
fchosphère c'est l'ensemble
des des sites internet et des des mecs
qui sont d'extrême Morat qui sont qui
sont
euh qui sont mobilisés qui qui montrent
leur présence ou leur désaccord sur sur
des articles ou sur ou qui publient
leurs propres articles ou c'est des des
des c'est c'est un rseau intern une
gauchosphère à côté de ça ouais il y a
une gauchosphère je pense qu'elle est
euh
je pense qu'elle est moins active j'ai
l'impression qu'elle est moins active
mais elle existe aussi forcément et elle
est elle est également présente sur
notre site les deux enfin les deux se se
répondent euh donc sur les problèmes sur
les sur les sur les questions nationales
ils sont souvent pas d'accord sur les
questions internationales ils sont
parfois d'accord je pense qu'il y a pas
vraiment de de règles quel est votre
plus vot plus beau succès et votre plus
beau plantage chez sputnck un plus beau
succès
c'est d'avoir publié les extrêmes
manquants de l'interview de Vladimir
Poutine sur TF1 il avait caché tout
enfin il avaient coupé au montage tout
un tas de trucs sur la politique
internationale l'importance d'un monde
multipolaire qui avait été coupé qu'on
les a
publié et votre plus gros
ratage plus gros ratage j'étais pas là
euh
mais
c'est au tout début de Spoutnick
Spoutnick a commencé en février et en
mars il y avait cet avion de la
luftansza qui s'estécrasé dans les Alpes
avec le pilote qui qui sétait enfermé
dans la cabine et qui s'était suicidé en
jetant contre une montagne quoi
et il y a
une une journaliste qui n'était qui
n'était pas permanente chez nous he mais
qui qui avait un un blog ouvert à
l'intérieur du du site de spoutnck qui
avait dit que c'était la CIA qui qui
avait fait écraser et c'est passé et
c'est passé parce qu' publié directement
c'est passé c'est resté c'est c'est
resté très très peu de temps sur le site
donc c'est votre RAC chef qui qui
s'occupe de toute la discrimination des
news à sortir et vous avez un bord
quelque chose des des journalistes
référents pour faire votre ligne
éditoriale de la journée ou c'est bah
non on se réunit le matin et on fait oua
on fait la ligne vous avez des
connexions avec les autres salles de
rédaction de sputnque monde on essaye on
a je crois qu'on a peu les mêmes
problématiques de d'être pressé d'avoir
d'avoir une émission radio à gérer du
matin pour le soir donc on on communique
pas autant que moi je le voudrais parce
qu'on a enfin c'est c'est un formidable
réseau je veux dire c'est comme
euh d'avoir d'avoir des bureaux partout
dans le monde on a envie de dire allô
qu'est-ce que tu penses de ça qu'est-ce
que on aimerait même donc ça se
développe euh ça se développe c'est pas
encore tout à fait suffisant mais mais
mais on y arrive à mieux communiquer
entre d' d'un bureau à l'autre est-ce
que vous pensez que vous êtes
transparent avec votre public
transparent avec notre public
euh je cherche je cherche ce que tu veux
dire par là en fait est-ce qu'on dit
est-ce qu'on dirait
is moi nous nous on est un peu un cas
particulier c'estàdire que quand on veut
quelqu'un on va le chercher quoi qu'il
arrive vous nous avez vu débarquer en
général on prend pas euh des des petits
talons pour venir taper à la porte donc
pour nous vous rentrez dans le cadre de
la transparence c'estàd que quand on a
besoin de vous parler il y a quelqu'un
pour nous répondre et il y a quelqu'un
pour venir nous parler donc là le
rédacteur en
chef a été pris par d'autres impératif
et il m'a envoyé nous a envoyé son
porte-parole donc il y a quand même un
dialogue qui s'effectue c'est correct
mais est-ce que vos lecteur vous demande
plus de transparence par rapport à tous
les colibés ou les réprimandes ou les
les remarques que la presse française
peut vous faire en tant
que service de soupe de Moscou des
choses comme ça estce que vous avez pris
en considération le fait nous nous on
vous a reçu uniquement pour ça parce que
notre communauté nous disait allez voir
sputnque allez voir o parce que on
trouve qu'ils sont pas très transparents
donc nous on y a été vous avou comment
vous faites pour on est financé à 100
% par le gouvernement voilà bah c'est
au-delà de ça la transp est-ce que vos
lecteurs vous demandent plus de
transparence sur comment vous
construisez l'information comment votre
salle de rédaction fonctionne qui est le
dernier mot ou des choses comme ça non
non non non on a pas reçu ce genre de de
demande vraiment ben nous on vous le
demande être plus transparent on demande
à tous les médias d'ailleurs France 2
France 3 la construction de
l'information votre avis sur les fake
news qu'est-ce que c'est est-ce que
c'est une des opérations de spin doctor
de différents États se menant une
bataille de l'information sur nos
réseaux non les fake new je pense que
c'est des gens perdus qui essayent de
s'inventer une réalité ou de vendre leur
propre leur propre soupe non les fake
news je pense que
c'est c'est un un sous-produit de
l'Internet ça va avec ou un sous-produit
du journalisme ou un ou un bah non la
limite je crois que c'est plus lié à
l'Internet
c'estàdire le le revers de la médaille
tout le monde peut s'exprimer sur
internet ça c'est super
maintenant certains si il y a toujours
eu des des rumeurs des choses et le fait
que une rumeur puisse être est-ce que
c'est la faute des
journalistes est-ce que les journalistes
de tout bord n'ont pas laissé le terrain
libre à toutes les propagandes parce
qu'ils faisaient pas leur taf parce qu'
il connaissaient pas la convention de
Munich
euh et bah ouais
hein non non moi je pense vraiment que
les les fake news c'est c'est c'est lié
à à la la la possibilité qui est donnée
à tout à chacun de de construire de
construire une info fausse
euh et ensuite si elle est populaire si
elle répond à un
désir de l'audience elle va se répandre
comme une traînée de poudre comme une TR
poudre je dire le gorfi fait ça en très
drôle euh mais on peut faire ça en très
paranoïque ou en très bref on peut
s'appuyer sur une émotion est-ce que
sputnque fait du putaclic du putaclic
euh c'est-à-dire des des des titres AG
guuicheurs ou des nouvelles un peu AG
guicheuses ah les titres AG guuicheurs
on essae enfin on essaie d'avoir un
effectivement des des titres des titres
qui accrochent mais en même temps on
fait attention à ce qui à ce que le
contenu de
l'article
soit corrobore corrobore ce titre
euh maintenant
euh maintenant chaque chaque chaque
journal fait fait dans les dans les les
les sujets un
peu aucune valeur journalistique je sais
pas les plus belles femmes de
footballeur j'ai vu dans le monde un
singe qui un singe avoir des relations
sexuelles avec une antilope dans le
monde voilà ça ça fait du clique nous on
fait pas trop ça on aurait préféré fait
nous on fait on fait un truc on fait un
truc mais un truc qui est qui est pas
qui est pas trop repris par les autres
journaux les ovenis ouais voilà on fait
plutôt dans les martiens nous on fait
plutôt dans les Mar c'est un sujet
défendable comme un autre hein voilà
c'est-à-dire que les gens les les les
nouvelles qu'on qu'on donne sont
proviennent de de chercheurs il y a des
il y a tout un tas de gens qui bossent
des astrophysiciens machin ils bossent
ils bossent sur il cherchent des signaux
extraterrestres et quand il faut une
découverte on en parle alors de là à
dire de là à
dire enfin de la dire qu'on fait du du
putaclic parce que on parle de la
possibilité euh d'une vie extraterrestre
je pense que d'un point de vue
journalistique c'est risqué de parler de
la possibilité
d'un d'une vie extraterrestre maintenant
euh d'un point de vue euh strictement
euh voilà d'un point de vue strictement
statistique la possibilité qu'on soit
les seuls sur la planète et tout tout ça
c'est des choses qui se discute mais qui
ne se discute pas dans la presse
mainstream parce que ça fait dingue si
d'une baguette je vous offre une
baguette magique ouais vous pouviez
changer toute la presse vos trois
premières mesures ce serait
quoi bon appr prendre la convention de
Munich pour tous les journalistes je
suis d'accord bon ça je la garde pour
moi d'accord bon les trois
premières les trois premières ça
serait imposer des stages
au au au cœur des populations des stages
des stages ouais des stages des stages
pour déchiffrer l'information non non
non non des stages pour pour être un peu
en rapport
euh en rapport avec les en rapport avec
les gens être plus proche des gens être
moins sortir de cette espèce de clash
journalistique qui se comprend qui
s'entend et qui euh qui se répèteent les
uns les autres euh voilà euh non mais
c'est très bien d'avoir des des des
rapports confraternels voir corporatist
que d mais mais euh euh mais mais là là
je pense que c'est allé un peu loin je
pense que c'est allé un peu loin les
journalistes s'écoutent trop se font
trop confiance ils se remettent pas
assez en question connaissez
l'expression d'Internet euh non les
journalistes centre suus bah
complètement moi je quand j'étais au
Venezuela une fois je vois déboul
c'était il y avait quoi il y avait
cétait c'était sur sur la libération de
Bétancour ou ce genre enfin c'est même
pas ou ce genre c'était là-dessus et je
vois débouler les mec
un mec de R 1 un mec de
RTL qui me demande un fixeur donc je le
je leur donne un fixeur il voulaz pas
deux fixeurs non on va partager le même
fixeur ah d'accord et les mecs ils
bossaient ensemble ils faisaient les
mêmes papiers au même moment avec les
mêmes sources et ils sont de radio
concurrentes ça gêne pas ça
non bah de toute façon sa on pourra pas
faire mieux ok voilà il bossse ensemble
2è mesure euh 2e mesure
[Musique]
euh 2è mesure faudrait euh faudrait une
agence de presse qui soit
euh qui soit réellement
indépendante donc à défaut à défaut il
faut des agences de presse alternatives
mais l'idéal ce serait une agence de
presse qui soit vraiment indépendante
qui soit euh libre des intérêts
américains ou anglais ou français ou
russes euh qui puisse donner
une une vision une vision indépendante
du monde un vrai 4e pouvoir ouais bon et
trème mesure et trisème
mesure la la méritocratie à l'intérieur
de la presse je dire il y a il y a y a
moi j'ai vu des gens monter des gens
pour qui peu d'estime à la base mais en
tant que personne et puis aussi parce
que je lesai trouvais pas fine ni
cultivée monté par par
euh comment on dit
euh ils étaient tellement
conformiste tellement ils sortaient pas
de la ligne qu'au fur et à mesure au fur
et à mesure il faisaient de pas de
conneries les autres qui étaient un peu
moins conformiste au bout d'un moment
ping ah là tu t'es planté mec tu as pas
été sur la ligne ping et euh plus ils
étaient et les gens qui sont
conformistes et qui le sont tout tout le
long de leur carrière ils ont moins de
mal à faire carrière donc ils montent
plus haut plus vite et il se retrouve
avec des gens il a du conformisme chez
spoutnck
euh non non parce que je pense qu'on a
eu une une rédaction qui est très très
très variée j'ai jamais vu autant de
variété au sein d'une rédaction euh il y
a des gens qui sont
euh ça va de l'extrême gauche à
l'extrrême droite moi c'est la première
fois que je cohabite professionnellement
avec des gens d'extrême droite il y a
pas de l'extrême centre un peu non si si
il y a de l'extrême centre aussi euh du
enfin l'extrême centre de la la gauche
la gauche molle tu appelle-le comme tu
veux euh il y a des il y a de tout il y
a vraiment de tout et du coup chacun
chacun pousse son son son pion
et les autres parviennent à intéressé
est-ce que c'est problématique dans une
carrière de journaliste d'avoir
travaillé pour les Russes en France
grave ah ouais ouais c'est marqué c'est
que moi moi moi moi moi j'ai un un autre
métier donc
je je je sais que je sais je je souhaite
pas réintégrer réintégrer une rédaction
après ça mais je sais que si je l'avais
souhaité ça aurait été impossible enfin
dans en l'état actuel des choses c'est
quoi votre autre métier je suis
producteur de film quel type de film
documentaire
d'accord votre maison prod c'est quoi h
euh les films grand sable je fais autre
puis
je voilà entre autres hein je travaille
pour pour d'autres boîtes de prod mais
mais j'ai fait j'ai j'ai fait de la prod
depuis plusieurs années ça m'amuse
beaucoup on prend le temps je suis je
suis auteur également d'un d'un
documentaire en ce moment qui s'appelle
euh l'avenir de nos origines sur la
préservation en 3D du patrimoine
archéologique iraakien bon quoi
non mais c'est bien on peut enfin tu
vois moi je j'adore ça bon et votre
patron c'est un patron qui est gentil
qui est pas gentil je sais qu'il est
d'usage chez les Russes de taper sur son
patron ah bon ouais ah de grommeler de
grommeler sur son patron bah non moi je
pense que c'est c'est un est-ce que vous
pouvez formuler toutes les critiques en
face à face ouais ou alors imaginez-vous
c'est moi votre rédacteur en chefou
c'est quoi la plus grosse critique que
vous ayez à me formuler
euh tu devrais être plus souvent présent
à l'antenne tu devrais faire
plus tu
devrais il a il engagé un porte-parole
quand même merde ouais mais même en
quand quand il y a des sujets enfin je
veux dire sur les élections en Russie il
avait fait un papier hyper intéressant
une analyse poussée intelligente modéré
où il y avait il y avait vraiment il
donnait il
donnait il donnait une belle leçon
d'objectif de journalisme sur sur un
sujet qui était évidemment pas facile
parce
que le le Russie unit le parti de parti
de Vladimir Poutine était très en tête
dans les dans les intentions de vote et
dans les résultats et donc tu avais
toute la presse qui hurlait à la la
dictature et lui il avait là-dessus un
discours hyper intéressant où il disait
mais attendez il y a à l'intérieur de
Russie Unie les mêmes différences que
vous entre l'Ile gauche l'aile gauche du
PS et l'aile droite de
l'exump donc quel â il a le rédacteur en
chef 35 ans il a des enfants ouais il
habite où en
banlieu il
habite je sais pas ou il habite à Paris
il habite à Paris il pay ses impôts en
France ouais sa femme elle est française
ou elle est russe française ou
il est français quoi bah
ouais il est français ou il est russe
mais il est
français il est russe al moi j'ai une
oui les Russes comme enfin je sais pas
j'aurais tendance à dire de quelqu'un
qui est enAlgérie qui vit en France
depuis 20 30 ans qu'il est français
donc ça peut se plaquer aussi sur lui
voilà bon r vous avez des partenariats
vous êtes connectés a eux pas du tout
connecté à eux euh alors eux pour le
coup c'est très compliqué de les avoir
ouais on a appelé jusqu'à Moscou pour
les avoir on prod général de de de
Moscou mais pas de retour aant sputnque
ça va vite aant r
toutday est-ce que ça vous pose problème
que eux soient pas très
transparents bah moi je me sens pas je
bosse pas avec eux quoi je bosse pas
avec eux euh
euh euh ils ont ils ont ils ont leur
façon de bosser ils ont leur sources ils
ont beaucoup enfin ils ont plus de
moyens que
nous
euh et
euh et ils font un boulot enfin je veux
dire ils ont pasemp plan en Syrie ils
avaient des mecs sur place quoi quand
quand quand quand la presse française
faisait des articles incendiaire à
partir d'interview sur Skype eux ils
avaient des mecs sur place donc il sont
ont ils ont aussi leur vision du
journalisme et bon et ils y vont
franchement vous avez des questions à
nous poser euh
ouais moi c'est le bah non enfin
j'aurais bien une discussion à voir
parce que moi le le hacking le hacking
m'a toujours m'a toujours toujours
fasciné je trouve ça génial de pouvoir
enfin tout ce que ça permet maintenant
comment ça marche quelle
d'avoir envie est-ce que les les
hackeurs français sont puissants très
ouais très puissant en ouais d'après ce
qui tourne c'est 20 % des hackeurs
mondiaux du moins les 20 les 20 % des
des hackurs VI les 20 meilleurs pour
viennent de France ah ouais ouais c'est
la classe ça ouais c'est tout comme
comme question Benain non du coup du
coup pour qui bah pour pour qui vous
bossez du qui vous finance est-ce que
vous êtes
nous nous on est pas financé on est tous
bénévoles on fait ça
pour pas notre honneur mais pour que
notre communauté soit plus endurcie face
à vous les journalistes vous savez qu'on
vous déteste tous que vous soyez à
gauche à droite russe français américain
on a un regard qui est très très
critique sur votre corporation vous
feriez mieux ouais comment bah déjà on
vous vire tous ouais on vous fait tous
écrire 25 fois la charte de muniich
ouais et ensuite on vous fait passer
votre bac ah d'accord pourquoi le bac
pourquoi quel parce que quand on voit
certains journaliste écrire des papiers
c'est encore pire que nous pas ils
savent pas écrire français les gars ah
ouais et puis après trianguler une
source aller voir ce qui se passe faire
la nous on a une technique qui s'appelle
l' fait pourquoi vous le faites pas
parce que vous vous faites ça chos à
ouais et puis on na pas signé
pour être journaliste ni 4e pouvoir par
contre quand notre communauté vient nous
cher en disant voilà ma vie va mal parce
que l'information est de mauvaise
qualité h on est obligé d'un petit
peu je sais pas de serrer les coudes
avec nos copains d'école des gens qui
ont eu d'autres trajectoires ouais je
comprends et on a on a un point de vue
qui est très critique sur les
journalistes alors on les prend bah de
temps en temps on leur explique un peu
les choses en face notre mécontentement
et on leur montre qu'on est capable de
faire mieux qu'eux et qu'ils arrêtent de
faire les malins parce que que ils sont
tout petits on est toujours plus petit
que certains nous aussi on est plus
petit que d'autres mais on a décidé de
faire ça pour endurcir notre communauté
et pour peut-être améliorer les choses
du moins on est censé faire un petit peu
ce que vous faites c'est-à-dire apporter
une information de bonne qualité pour
que les gens puissent avoir de quoi
prendre une décision en âme et
conscience
ouais en même temps en même temps sur
des sur des problématiques d'actualité
quelle décision on a enfin on a on a on
est plus et vous comme nous hein on est
plus spectateur spectateur que qu'acteur
on on a la possib faut pas tomber dans
le misérabilisme de l'impuissance du
journalisme mon ami hein il ne faut pas
tomber dans le misérabilisme de
l'impuissance un journaliste pour nous
ça doit être quelqu'un une tête brûlée
qui va chercher l'information quoi quoi
que ça lui en coûte quoi que ça lui en
coûte sa carrière sa famille ses enfants
son emprunt sa carte de presse sa belle
bagnole et la belle pépée qu'il aime
bien sortir dans tous les vernissages
qui va traîner avec ses copains
journalistes surtout parisiens on les
voit les gars on les voit ouais bon les
les dernières question qu'on va vous
poser à vous laissz un conseil pour les
jeunes générations c'est une question
qui est commune à toutes nos
interviews donc c'est une bouteille à la
mer sur Internet
h faut pas se
contenter faut pas se contenter d'une
seule source faut faut faut vraiment
faire un un gros effort pour euh se
mettre à la place de à la place des des
autres et surtout pas oublier que au
final il y a il y a des gens derrière
tout ça
euh
derrière derrière ce qui se passe en
Syrie il y a des gens qui croient à la
Révolution il y a des gens qui croient
au djihad il y a des gens qui croient au
Bachar euh qu'il faut pas croire que que
parce que nous on considère euh que
Bachar ou Sadam Hussein ou machin sont
des tyrans il y a pas des gens ou
Poutine il y a pas des gens nombreux qui
sont derrière eux et que c'est pas parce
que Poutine a une popularité qui F les
80 % que Y a 80 % de Russes qui sont
cons
voilà ivonl merci merci à vous
[Musique]